winter is coming and I'm thinking about
moving south Game of Thrones Season 5
episode 8 hardhome I can say
unequivocally favorite episode of the
season so far
Bar None I like what happens in this
episode cuz a lot act like truly burly
big steps stuff happens
I like a lot of the interactions that
happened I like the way things pan out
everything feels properly earned or it
feels like it's building towards a
chance where we're gonna get a proper
earned conclusion on it we get some
pretty big payoffs in this I mean if we
get payoff on something that was
basically teased in a buddy because it
was a bone a little lure that was thrown
at us not only in the first episode of
in the first teasers then we get nice
payoff on that and it's in the way it
plays out and the scene that happens
around it is just terrific it's great
and that's all stuff that's going on in
marine slimes Bay and all that
Arya's story feels like it's actually
progressing because she was her story
was one of the numerous ones that felt
very wheel spinning for a while and I
get that you know it was gonna have to
take a while for her story to really get
going because otherwise it was gonna
feel rushed it was gonna feel like she
didn't properly earn it but I feel like
they could have done more to make it
more interesting up to this point but
yeah now we're getting somewhere
we spent a little time in King's Landing
that is a little bit wheel spinning but
and then that is truly probably my only
complaint is barely a complaint because
we don't waste a lot of time there most
of the time is spent up in the north a
little bit of Winterfell and Sansa I'm
continuing to actually start to come to
like her she's she's right on the
precipice if she can just head the right
direction I will actually start to
genuinely like her as the character I'm
not quite there yet but I'm I'm excited
to get there I want to get there but
really really what we're talking about
we got to get up further north for the
real stuff that goes down and obviously
can't talk too much about stuff spoilers
and all that but there's some really
good scene some really good interactions
and some really phenomenal action
definitely the best action is in this
season I think arguably some of the best
action of the show so far just the way
everything was planned out in the way
it's executed the pace
of it the way everything bills and how
there's little climaxes building to a
larger climax I mean it's it's epic its
its season finale level epic but we've
still got two more episodes to go and
I'm really excited to see them I think
this is probably gonna be the shortest
one I've ever done because I just really
liked this episode and I really liked
what was going on about it I can't tell
you why too much because spoilers so
hooray feet those leg kicks are finally
back on track and I'm just hoping for a
really knock them dead last two episodes
because after kind of how the first half
of this seasons gone I really need it
but this was a great way to set up the
conclusion of the season so come on guys
let's bring it home so let me ask you
this one since I'm at this point
declaring this one my favorite episode
of the season what is your favorite
episode of Game of Thrones at all go
ahead pull from any season or give your
favorite of each season that works too
whatever it is that you think drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned